Israel y Líbano han alcanzado un acuerdo
histórico sobre sus fronteras marítimas
una disputa sobre 860 kilómetros
cuadrados de mar en el Mediterráneo
Oriental que alberga dos codiciados
yacimientos de gas ambas partes han
acogido con satisfacción el acuerdo que
contó con la mediación de Estados Unidos
el Primer Ministro de israelí y a ir
lapid lo ha calificado de Gran avance
el gobierno en libanés insiste en que no
ha comprometido su posición negociadora
ha obtenido todos sus derechos y se han
tenido en cuenta todas sus observaciones
a pesar de los rumores de que el Líbano
no recibió ninguna de sus demandas
Líbano las Ha obtenido todas porque son
demandas legítimas
tras haber amenazado previamente con
bloquear el acuerdo incluso hesbolá
enemigo de Israel ha dado luz verde la
zona se ha estado negociando de 2020 con
ambos países reclamando el yacimiento de
gas de carish rico en hidrocarburos y el
hasta ahora inexplorado yacimiento de
Cana
los detalles del acuerdo aún no se han
hecho públicos pero se entiende que
carish pertenecerá a Israel y Líbano
controlará la explotación del yacimiento
de caná un consorcio liderado por el
gigante energético francés total energys
se encargará de la explotación y la
exploración pagando un Canon a Israel
sobre cualquier beneficio futuro Desde
que la guerra del Líbano de 2006 terminó
en un alto el fuego con una resolución
del Consejo de Seguridad de la ONU los
dos países han permanecido oficialmente
en guerra de 2019 Líbano se encuentra
asumido en la peor crisis de liquidez de
su historia si el yacimiento de gas
decana resulta próspero podría ser su
salvavidas económico